See everybody that's on here is a veteran, so we won't go through the first few slides
Do look at the announcements next Monday, we will not have a Zoom call and end because of Labor Day and
September 8th
There is day after Labor Day
She has to move her genetic Zoom call to 11
Instead of two
But that does not affect anybody who hasn't received a notice from her and email notice that it's
Time to join the genetic Zoom call. Here's all your genetic information
And
We just do that one time
So we will be first to your genetic review
So no Monday Zoom call next week because of Labor Day and
September 8th not tomorrow, but September 8th next week
The genetic Zoom if your genetics are ready and you'll get an email and say that they are it'll be moved to 11 o'clock
Okay questions that came in I recently read that patients with a dreidel insufficiency
Should be careful of taking a dreidel or thyroid support compounds because they won't
They may contain T3 and may contain potent synthetic
glucocorticoids to your knowledge does that apply to
Ego thyroid 37
so
Thyroid support
Products are typically glandular and same thing with a dreidel support a glandular product
Now that's different from an adaptogen adaptogens are specific herbs that are in that category of adaptogenic herbs that can help balance your hormones either way
But I think this person is talking about glandular support and yes, glandular thyroid can contain
Some that's not actually thyroid hormone that's a possibility
But typically glandular thyroid and a glandular a dreidel is just stimulating that organ
So just because it contains a glucocorticoid does not make it's gonna increase glucose levels
So don't get confused with those two things just because your T3 gets secreted naturally by your thyroid does not increase your
glucose levels, so it doesn't change your glucose levels and it's not gonna change
Really have much effect on cancer whatsoever the only effect that high-poled thyroid
Has on cancer would be
Just you're physically tired really your thyroid. No, there is some maybe tertiary connection to your immune system
It doesn't have a direct effect on your immune system
Nor does your adrenals have a direct effect on your immune system
But it stands to reason if you're just in constant fatigue because you have adrenal insufficiency
Your immune system could also have some suppression to it. I don't know the I haven't seen a studies that show direct correlation
They're sure since it can't separate anything in the body. There may be some connection
Certainly I am I don't but I don't believe the statement that said here at all that taking
Adrenal or thyroid
Support is going to
Increase your
glucose levels to understand what local corticoids do is they
That is secreted not by your thyroid at all. It's created by your adrenal gland
Cortisol is a glucocortisol coid and it breaks down bike agent stores in your liver
Um, and it has a direct purpose. So if you're under a lot of stress, you need more glucose because
Emotional stress you're gonna be birding glucose faster in your brain and physical stress
You're gonna have a call for glucose to your muscles
So if you go out for a brisk walk your adrenals aren't gonna kick in you're gonna release some cortisol
Another glucocorticoids. So you break down
glycogen stores in your liver for the purpose of
using them for
Created ATP in your muscle cells as that glucose metabolizes through glycolysis of a crev cycle to make ATP
You need glucose. You need to burn glucose to make energy
For your brisk walk same thing if you're under a ton of emotional stress
Your cortisol is gonna be um released by your adrenal glands and
Because your braid is birding more glucose under that emotional stress
It's the same same principle also cortisol the glucocortis points are released in the middle of the night
For the purpose of keeping your braid alive your braid feeds on glucose and if
If you don't have that
Glucocorticoid release by your adrenal glands at one two three o'clock in the morning
That is one of the major things that causes people to wake up in the middle of the night
So many people with adrenal insufficiency where their adrenals are completely fatigued
Then they they don't have enough output of
Adrenal gland function. They don't have enough output
um
Glucocorticoids
Then
They are the ones that you know, I seem to be able to fall asleep at night a function of melatonin
So they don't have an issue there. I get to sleep at night
But then I wake up about one o'clock and I can't get back to sleep
So it's that's different that I get to sleep at night
I wake up at one o'clock because I have to go to the bathroom
But I can fall back asleep pretty quick
But after wake up at three o'clock as I have to go to the bathroom
But I can fall back asleep
Well, you might have an issue with your bladder
You might have an issue. Prostate is a male
But if you can fall back asleep pretty good
You don't have at least you don't have adrenal insufficiency
So you don't have adrenal complete adrenal fatigue
So with complete adrenal fatigue
Even though you might be able to make it through the day
That's where you see the typical. I can't go back to sleep at night
If you take adrenal support
I mean, yeah, I guess if you took the whole bottle of
of a desiccated to Doritos
Could you have an abundance of glucocorticoids that
You're still only going to break down what your your glycogen stores are in your liver
So glucocorticoids in themselves are not in themselves are not glucose
They break down glycogen stores in your liver
Um, and I don't think eco thyroid is an effect at all
So if you're taking a normal dose of that to help balance your
Doritos or your thyroid
That's not really an issue
With cancer as far as spiking you're going to close
I have a relative who's pediatrician. Oh, this was a question for less to carry
This was a question for less
Yes, it's a question. So I guess I
So I want to have a bunch of questions in different ways
Okay, this was a good question. It has been 10 weeks since
I said to genetic testing
wondered how much longer we'll take
Well, I do know who sent in this question and your genetics are back already know it takes several days for him to
Work through them and get the whole plan for genetics to be put together
So she will email you. So if you're like I wonder what my genetic testing is please
Don't hesitate to ask a question on here
Because sometimes the genetics can get lost in the shuffle
Um, uh, they're a genetic company communicating to us. So it's good that you ask that question
Second, is there a difference between the caster oil packs and coffee enemies since they're both
To help the liver. Yes, there's a big difference complete difference caster oil packs over your liver
With heat of them if you're doing it correctly
You do absorb some of the caster oil that could help benefit flushing the liver, but mainly
That heat will help
Uh, the liver you add heat to tissue you're gonna add flow and motion to that tissue
You're gonna decrease viscosity of the bile
You'll help the bile flow so it'll help with detox pathways that way
The difference with coffee in the liver coffee in a stimulated cranial nerve 10 the vagus nerve
So it's a neurological response that chemical response or physical response as it is with heat
So a neurological response you're stimulating the vagal nerve stimulating the parasympathetic nervous system
Which is also stimulated not just detoxification pathways in the liver, but it stimulates peristaltic waves in the
A small intestine and it stimulates your immune system. So coffee enemas
For immune stimulation is
You know really the main reason why you're doing coffee enemas are neurological stimulation
Question on the chat. I make my own granola and plaques hemp and chia seeds
I included them in the mixture that I roast are 250 am I affecting the omega-3 or other nutritional value of those seeds
When you roast them
Uh, yes, I'm sure you are so you are possibly
You know you can denature a fat if you cook it at too high a temperature 250 is at a super high temperature
Um, for instance, it's recommended you use coconut oil if you're going to
um
Cook something on your stove like some fish
Versus olive oil if you're cooking at a high heat because coconut oil is more stable in a high heat
Olive oil the way a gas it is less stable in a high heat
So cooking that at a
Using a lower heat to cook that 250 degrees would be considered a lower heat
So I don't think your denature in much of the way
I listen to most of the videos that I can find
That I could find and I read the notebook
The binder I think they're talking about
I may have missed it as I am sure it's including the info somewhere, but
When under the bed sheets where exactly is the bulb supposed to be was it supposed to be directly on your stomach your abdomen just sitting next to you
Well, that's a good question um
Uh, the bulb should be as close to the site of cancer as possible
Let's say I have stage four metastatic cancer all over my body just put it up to your abdomen
It's going to go through you, but let's say let's say you have
You know your cancer is just in your leg. It's nowhere else. You have a sarcoma on your lower right leg
I may be tempted to put the bulb you know down low near my leg and maybe even hold it between the legs while I sleep
We have some patients with brain cancer that put the bulb right up on their brain
Their head um, I typically discourage that because the light can keep them awake
But I have one patient who goes no does keep you awake. I love it. I put it right over my head
That's fine if it doesn't keep you awake. You're still all right. You need to get your sleep, too
If you have breast cancer, you just snuggle it on your abdomen
Right, it's your upper abdomen your chest
um
Yeah, you know pretty much any cancer would be that you know
You have a sarcoma on your neck maybe you put it up a little bit higher, but again you want to
Make sure it doesn't keep you awake
So if you have to keep it under the covers whoever you need to do it
The idea is the closer it is to you the better
I mean, you're still going to get treatment if it falls by your side and
And you roll over and you're really restless embedded it's three feet away
But if it's right up next to you, you're going to get better treatment from it
I'm feeling a little bit light headed or blurry the last three days
I take my powders and vitamins that quite sure what's causing the feeling feels like my head
but not sure what
So um, I do know the person who asked this question has
um
A tumor cancer in their brain. So but even if that wasn't the case
Let's say this was a liver cancer question somebody with liver cancer
Whatever you feel a little bit light headed or blurry like that
The first thing that you think of the first thing that you should think of is blood sugar levels
Make sure that your blood sugar isn't completely taking in your hypoglycemic
How do I know that you can go get a little blue cometer and target
60 bucks or something like that that comes with figures strip
Testing the devices that you test the blood figure tip
Prick um, and that is a good way to test that now
What are normal levels? Well, it has to do whether you or do the 12 hour faster not
But they should be less than 125 unless you just ate something
Um, uh, and you did your blood test your
The blood sugar could be higher than that but two hours after eating you really should be back
You know
Somewhere between 70 and 100 that would be really goal if you ate two hours ago you did a fingerprint test in your blood sugar is 55
Um, you then you want to start testing and see what's normal for you
It might be normal at 55 that you really low blood sugar that would be technically hypoglycemic
However, if you're on a ketogenic diet, that's kind of where you want to be and so then
Then low normal would be 45 for a person on a ketogenic diet
So it really depends on what your normal is based upon your diet
Secondly, when you have feelings like this. Let's say your blood sugar is normal
Um, then you start thinking of inflammation in the brain
so
Inflammation in the brain can be caused from all sorts of things even if you have brain cancer it doesn't mean the cancer is growing
Inflammation in the brain is most commonly caused from
Inflammation from your diet
So if you have a gluten sensitivity and you might not even know about you've been eating pretty gluten free
But then you ate a bunch of gluten yesterday. That's going to cause an inflammatory response of the gut
Which is going to affect your gluteal morphine receptors in your brain. You're going to have inflammation in your brain
Guaranteed and if you already have a space occupied lesion in your brain, you're going to feel it even worse
Likewise, if you're under a lot of stress and you have a lot of
um birdied
Of glucose and
Glutamates in your brain
Because you've been burning the candle at both ends and then you add on top of it
Some sort of inflammatory response anything that causes inflammation you're going to feel it in the brain
And that's what you should think about
So
First think about your glucose levels are you hypoglycemic second think about what could have caused inflammation of the brain if that is true
Trying to deal with what that cause would be case of gluten or dairy
Um or any other food sensitivity if this happens every once in a while start putting your figure on what could possibly be causing it remember any inflammation of the gut inclusive inflammation of the brain
And then um
Uh, so then try to identify and cut that back
Then next go higher dose on your flavonoids
Increase your curcumin increase your residual increase your buzzwellia your sting middle your corseted things like that those are the
Things study after study that are that will decrease inflammation in your brain
And then do not discount if you have any history
Um cancer in the brain
Um or a cancer that can be testicized in the brain if these things aren't combing this down and you're not noticing a change
Do make sure you get back to your ecologist and get that checked
So we don't want to ignore we don't want to jump always to the oh, it's it's my cancer. That's what it is
Because it makes it's not
Most times now, but you don't want to ignore that either so um look at those positive ways
Uh
Question on Monday's call it so I don't like it was saying that I could take by poters
To my green veg smoothie is that okay? Yes, I use
um
Some spectrum grades first and corseted
Can you take can you take your poters add them to your smoothie? Yes
Yes, you can put all those together
Absolutely. Yep
Next question. I am interested in getting a sleep number adjustable bed
Do these types of bed give off high efs are they saying to use
No, I don't think they give off my efs member these are just they have an electric motor in them
Um, and the motor isn't ruddy
Unless you are you know pushing the button to move
The bed that it's activating the motor and the hydraulics on the bed
So if you're not using it, it's not giving you should be giving up 80 efs and a little electric motor is like that
Don't really give off much eb if I remember them to give off 80 efs
So very similar to the question we had last week
Oh, can I use an electric chair?
Um, that uh the electric recliders I'm pretty sure they don't give off any eb so I'm yes, I'm sure they're safe to use
My husband has put on 30 pounds of fluid it is abdomen a pair
Said a pair of the thesis did not provide relief
Lasix is also not providing any relief
We are currently ready programs for a sitey swelling and liver health on the rife
Do you have any other recommendations for fluid retention at a sitey's
Um, we do have a herbal
Diuretic on the store we we just we just got it a while ago
We haven't had very many people try it so I don't have a lot
Testibodials on how well it worked, but that might be something to look at
I would also
Look at if there are 30 pounds of fluid in the abdomen
Um, maybe look at going somewhere else to get the exam about fluid and getting it drained
Um, maybe the place that you're going to
isn't really
equipped with experience
Uh, getting uh, getting a good look at where the fluid fluid is pocketing and where it could be drained
Because that seems like an awful lot of fluid
There's got to be several leaders there that I would think that could be captured and not known of all
I would look somewhere else
We have had patients over the years that have gone to their ecologist and
And they have to make an appointment and to get their
drained of their abdominal fluid or lung fluid and that's been a pain or and sometimes it's equated to the ER
Uh, the local hospital they get better service
So think about that as well
Uh, the MD at the alternative clinic where I get my vitamin C and ALA IVs wants me to take a daily dose of
Ivermectin uh, she says it's a cancer fighter
What does Dr. Cutter's opinion of Ivermectin?
Um, it um, can be a good thing
Legally, I can't tell you to take Ivermectin because it is a prescription medication
Um, but um, there's studies out that Ivermectin had helped with cancer
So I mean, if it was me, I would give it a shot
There's really not a whole lot of negatives about Ivermectin
So
Also, she said my methylation is a bit low
What's we to take methyl CPG my ortho molecular products
I would say no to that um, and the reason why I say no to that is that methyl groups
turn genes off and we don't want to be turning uh, tumor suppressor genes off
That's one of the main issues with people with cancer is they have already stymied tumor suppressor genes
Um, we don't want to overbethylate
I'd rather have a person be underbethylated or only getting their methyl groups solely from their diet
Where do you get methyl groups from your diet from foliage?
foliage your greens
Your green leafy vegetables are your best source of methylation
I don't want people. It's just my opinion. Do you want to do it?
When I don't want my patients taking methyl groups
A chiropractor has given me homeopathic drops to get rid of my lymph will be better
And drops because he said I was over acid
That'll know um, what he's talking there
But um, certainly homeopathic drops are very safe. I would say yes
Go for it. I think uh, there's no harm in that. So
When using the rife
Should the wires from the true rife to the hammerbone cross over
If they do one of the consequences
Might almost always cross over to or the rife being very close to my bed
Um
Micah true rife says just to be careful that they're not
Crossied over like you're a tangled mess
So it's pretty impossible not to have them cross
Um
It could
If there was a cut in the wire or something like that
Could you get it what's called an arc?
Um, yes, you could. Did you notice that and you'd share that and you
There would you notice there's something wrong
Um, if they're tangled all up, that's not good for the wires
You don't want that to take place
But it's almost impossible to not have them cross
So um, yes, it'd be perfect if they were perfectly straight and
And you wouldn't have any issues at all ever happening with it
But mine are always crossed, but they're not in a take-go the best so try to keep order
So that um, you'll get proper flow through the wires
But the wires are fully encased in their little plastic casing
Shouldn't be any issues with that
Long question or to keep it this form
Curious as to Dr. Cutter's take on the following
Um, I have been eating a lot of fruit
Uh quote sugars feed cancer is another tremendous myth to claim sugars feed cancers to die with decades of science is proven
To starve the body for a sugar that is
Is to starve the cell of its energy
This causes cancer starvation acidosis ketosis damages cells
A damaged cell is on its walk down the road to atypical and becoming a cancer cell
Assets of course are what damage a cell in the first place
Acidosis is caused by eating proteins and refined fats or too many supplemental fatty acids
Remember the body is simplistic more is not better
Less is oftentimes better that is fasting of all types under eating etc
Acids are corrosive and damage the cell when lugs lymphatic system can no longer filter them through one's kidneys
Acids create inflammation and the
Parasite responds to the above
Um as said glucose and fructose are only simple sugars to say a fruit meets cancer is also saying vegetables feed cancer
This is all stupid thinking
Even the American cancer society recommends a five fruit and vegetable diet
The whole concept of diseases is a fabrication of the AMA chemistry in the physics rule
There is simply cause
There is simple
Simply cause and affect no labels from Dr. Morse
And the question goes on here
More about sugar speed cancer
um
So I write about this in my book. I would agree partially with this. I mean this you can decide what you want to do
You're going to it sounds like Dr. Morse is more of a fruitarian. So there are people
That um believe that you should only eat fruit and that's what you should live on. So there's so you could
Look up on YouTube my fruitarians and there's people that teach people how to be fruitarians and all they do is eat fruit
Well, is there anything wrong with that? Well, I would say
I don't I wouldn't say there's anything wrong with anything
I mean if you look at that into an Indians who survived solely on eating
whale blubber
How in the world they didn't eat protein they didn't eat any vegetable vegetables and they most certainly did not eat one
speck of fruit
They ate whale blubber and they lived to a ripe old age
Well, is it because their genetics are different? Well, you can't have a different enough genetics to make a difference in
That strict amount of change of diet
The truth is is that your body is
Is um is unbelievable and how it could adapt to your environment
um, and how it can change
Foods that you eat to different intermediate metabolites in order for you to survive
It can take those fats from whale blubber and
Even from that break them down to be able to
survive and somehow some way make enzymes because you need protein to make enzymes
And survive just as much as you can take a person who's a fruitarian who's eating you know all sugar basically
You know because sugar is
simple and complex carbohydrates
And yet they're not eating they're eating
No protein and yet they could still survive
But by my only dispute with
This type of thinking is is simply philosophical
I you know when we start say that this always
causes this or this is always bad or this is always good we do have to be careful
Yeah, we can say that yeah drinking poison is always bad
But when we talk about foods that were created for us to eat
You know see in my mouth that I'm not against eating
fruit
But everything has to be in balance and I do believe that certain cancers can feed off of certain things
Um to say that sugar doesn't feed cancer
I'm sorry, but I just disagree with this person sugar certainly can feed cancer
But also to say that sugar always feeds cancer
In that case, I would agree with this person because that I think is wrong
But it is not a myth that sugar can feed cancer cancer is your own cells
In order for a metamorphosis to take place in a cell it needs glucose
So theoretically if you starve it from glucose you could slow down the metabolic process
In the process if if that person's cancer cells are mainly feeding off of amino acids
You're basically feeding the cancer because what else are you going to eat if you're not eating any sugar
You're going to probably need proteins
So that you could be feeding the cancer so um you know we do testing to try to figure that out
But we're not always right certainly you can test yourself that I talk about that in my book too
You could go out at total ketogenic diet
Which is absolutely no sugar you're not eating any
Simple carbohydrates you eat any fruit and you're staying away from vegetables that have a high glycemic index
So you're really reducing your blood glucose so you're trying to burn ketels
And you cannot you cannot argue with me that there's been patients with
Especially brain cancers that have gone on a ketogenic diet that that isn't literally shut down their cancer and save their life
But the same thing with somebody with the breast cancer maybe they go on a ketogenic diet and your cancer girls aren't crazy
Because their cancer was not feeding off of sugar it might have been feeding off of protein
So everybody's different and I think the wisest approach to take is to go
Hey, I'm going to learn from Dr. Morse. Maybe he's right for me
Um and everybody has a different opinion and and we're entitled to that
That's the beauty of life and it's so sad about our society as well
Because we're forced to take the opinion of some
Quotal quote specialist or quote unquote scientist and we have to quote unquote trust the science
Which has led people down a pathway that is
basically
Helped their destruction and we need to be critical thinkers
I think it's great that this patient went to a doctor that gave them a different opinion now they could take that information
Oh, maybe I should try that for a couple months and see how it does with my cancer or at least think about you know
Trying that are free about trying that there's nothing wrong with doing that. I spoke to a patient a few weeks ago that
Has a brain tumor and his
I was speaking to his parents and asked they asked about doing a ketogenic diet and I was convinced of how you're gonna
Take this young person this young adult and get them
Convince to do a ketogenic diet because hard but then that the child came out of child the young adult came out
He's like I want to do it. It's like calling cow great good for you. Let's go for it. Go for it. Let's try it
That's that that's that's a curious behind that's what we want say that's hey
I'm gonna give this to try and see if this can shrink it to
Nothing you do is to be permanent. You can make these changes and give it a try so hats off for looking into this
Next question
I am pretty sure my leukemia was set off by shedding from a foster girl at her home and then
Getting COVID within two weeks and then the leukemia symptoms showed up
Two weeks after that. So if those on this call don't know what shedding is shedding is the phenomena that happens when
A person is is vaccinated especially with an mRNA vaccination and you are shedding that mRNA spike protein
To other people around you and I know there's differences in opinion
We have a lot of patients that were vaccinated. That's a choice that you made
That's not a choice that I made and you would have to put a gun to my head and I still wouldn't get vaccinated
So it's but that's my choice based upon my research that I did so I'm not judging you if you did
Can effects of shedding cause cancer
You have to be living under a rock to not know that that's true and if you don't believe that
Getting a mRNA vaccine
Could
spike a cancer that's growing inside you or even be at a cause of a cancer
You again that could be living under a rock and I'm looking at any of the research
That is just the truth. So I would agree with this person
That that very well could have been what spiked their cancer
Currently starting the third round of chemo as the first two
uh regimens failed by the end of
The month cycle when my white blood cell codes begin to recover the blast cells are taking off again
This happens with acute leukemias the blast cells can start growing which is
um a growth of uh a certain white blood cell that we don't want to take place
A concern I have is that I've
Also, alongside chemo that taken by supplements to pdf rife what detox coffee enemas hyperburetic oxygen
It's still no change in the class cells. I've asked my doc team about studies
They've seen are the correlation between covid and the vaccine and the increase in cancers and if there's any treatments with this in consideration of course
um
Studies only are starting to show for correlation with no treatment studies yet
Um wondering if you know of any alternative cancer treatments that are specifically addressing the vaccine
um covid um
The catalyst
Yes, and I actually have some protocols so home on a pull them up and I'll show you the link
Uh for it. It's on our sister site my hope for lime.com
Because we have to take it off our cancer site because
They are
Sensoryness of Google is blocking us
Um, so let me go to the blog. I created a blog post in the video on this
Uh, but
So this is the blog post
And the videos
But if you just go to this here, I'll share
We go to this site
My hope for lime.com, okay?
My hope for deadline.com go to the blog
And my hope for lime.com
I have a rota article that says
Confused about the vxxx reactions xxxx protocols watch this
Um spike protein may damage DNA increasing cancer risk
Look at that targeted protocols to help detox from the vaccines
Look at that
Our video on that
Blog post with very targeted protocols to help detox from the vaccines
So look at that that gives you a lot of information that we'll call fun
Um
Everybody is a different opinion. I know it's different people like I said that it on this that have been vaccinated that have family that's vaccinated that you're living with
Is there a danger to that
Um, my opinion is there's
Yes, there's a large danger to that
Um and but you know you did what you did and you think you was the best
Not not community. Everybody's got to make that decision
Everybody's got to make their own choices
So if you think boy, maybe there wasn't a right choice and go to that site
My hope for lime and for the blog and you can look at different vaccine detox protocols
That make up
Next question. I'm trying to avoid dairy as a cancer driver which I've done
Good to side effects from the team of the world that I was on and
Just coming on two weeks of sores and mites are all making it very difficult to swallow it eat
I have protein shake that has way in it to the stand
Yes, don't you could have a protein shake with way in it. So that's fine
Okay, question uh, no, so if you just jumped in or jumped in late, we have a no zoom call next Monday. It's labor day
And September 8 genetic review if
And only if you got a notification from and that your genetics are back
It's been moved to 11 o'clock not tomorrow's but the eight
Question from the chat. How important is D3 which came to
Uh, so it depends on the person so if um
You have bleeding disorders that you don't want came to you don't want right of the K at all
You don't have bleeding disorders just for most people. Yes, who wanted I think you should take
All your fat soluble vitamins together. That's why we have
Rd supplement that has the dk2a and the e
All together. So I think there's benefit to taking the fat soluble vitamins all together
And think there's a synergistic relationship
What is the optimal amount of iodine to take can a person take too much
Uh, yes, you can't so
optimal amount of iodine to take
And the question is for whom for you for somebody else. It's different for different people. It's different if you have a thyroid condition
It's different if you have hyper thyroid graves disease um, so um
Uh, for the average person um, you know 10 milligrams of potassium iodine here is
Plenty for the really for the average person. They don't have to take any supplemental item
Um, there should be an iodine in the food that they take if they're taking greens first
There's probably I and there's I think there's iodine in that they're getting iodine minerals and nutrients that they're taking as well
If a person has breast cancer, sometimes there's a benefit to take you to increase iodine
If the person is around
Our radiation toxicity like a molecular fallout
Concerned like from the explosions in Japan and you're on the west coast and you want to protect your thyroid from
Radiation concerns that are coming over
By coastal tides and taking iodine can be beneficial
Because those radiation concerns can affect your thyroid
So um, that's up there if you're ideally with heavy metal toxicity iodine can be beneficial
Because it will help protect your thyroid. You won't take
We'll have as much pop take of the heavy metal into your thyroid
I like the iodine with kelp the slittle of iodine
personally um
That's the selenium
And uh the iodine plus iodine
As a product there are there's we have a good liquid iodine as well
My protein is low on my blood look is this from my diet
Um
Also since I started taking my brands my breasts has felt like
Like I pulled a muscle
Is this from the tumor changing
We'll do the second half of the question first um
That's very possible. So I mean that could be a good thing
I would think that if you feel a change in the tumor after taking
Uh a chemotherapy, I would consider that a good so um
First half of that question my protein is low on my blood work is this from my diet the answer is no
So even if you're on a very very low protein diet
Almost always your blood protein is gonna stay is not gonna cold the low dormal levels
Um low protein on blood work is these um let's call it an ominous side per cancer
It's really common with cancer patients to have low protein and it isn't because
Their diet is deficient in protein. So um it's not something that you could necessarily like oh I gotta you know
poultry that's my problem
um
That's really not what you want to do. So I would just
Not just ignore that, but I would set that aside and look at that look at that again as you're going through your treatment
It's not something that you would do an intervention for right now
The next question will scans pet skin emor ultrason
Show how much more yellow material is waiting to expel nearby blacks have crater film
um
Maybe
So if there is a fluid um will it show what a pet skin no will it show it an MRI
Probably will it show it an ultrason most likely yes
So a pet skin is only gonna show um where there's an increase
Um uptake of the glucose which is an increase in metabolic activity
um
So in an adult with already closed at the field at the
Easier plates of their bones
um
Increased uptake in a site typically especially somebody who has got a cancer diagnosis is an indication of a testis
Um, but it's not gonna show fluid. It's only showing the increase uptake so pet skin process on
MRI. Yes, you know, MRI will show a pocket of fluid ultrason definitely
So I'm gonna tell you what it is. I have results from it. Oh test and HR five tests from my biological dentist
Do they need to be in my final? It'd be good to have them in your file
um
If you get a test done remember anything and I have this on the test page if you get a test done from another practitioner
Ask that practitioner to go over the test um
That's that's something typically that will go over with you make sure they go over that test with you
But it's good to have it in your file. So please do send it to us. Yes
If there's something specific like my practitioner didn't understand this or I didn't
Explain this. We're very well. I'll try to explain that you know, maybe I'll do a better job. Maybe I'll do a workshop
You know, I'm you know, there's
You know, because me I'm gonna give you a better answer, but oh, I'm concerned with you guys
So you can send it to us if you do want that they don't make it a point
one of our doctors
um
Saddo would like to know the frequency I am doing so she could do their feedback treatments
um frequency you're doing with your life. I'm assuming
um, you can see the frequencies people people will often say
I want to know what frequencies I'm using
um a person can see their frequencies um, let me see if I can do this
I'm gonna show you guys
So when you run your program and look in for a picture and talk through this when you're writing your program
You see a little box with how much numbers and maybe some say they're maybe it says dwell pulse
um
And some other things
In there that those are the frequencies you're running to understand you're not just running one the frequency
You're running hundreds of frequencies
Um, maybe that's always there much, but you know anywhere between 15 to a couple hundred frequencies in a night program
So typically I'm not writing
programs where you're running frequencies more than three minutes per frequency
um, and sometimes it's only a few seconds per frequency for running a sweep program
So if I'm ready to sweep or through let's say
um, let's say 100.000 to 105
uh
Then it's
Then it's and it's going through the thousands it might only be on each frequency for a second
And that's going to be an hour to half right there
So you can see the frequencies in that left hand box
Please do not click on it or do anything in that box
Because you can mess up your program now you'd have to get saved to mess up your program and then you program by down run
Um, and then you then we get a call hey my Thursday night programs not running
I don't know what happened. Well usually it's someone accidentally you just kind of swiped over your touchpad of your computer
And you bite in
Hit something in that box and then we inadvertently saved it and then it messed up that program that I have to send you out of flash drive
So it overrides that hope your whole program so it fixes that Tuesday night program or whatever
So uh, you could see what frequencies are running you're running, you know frequency 475 and it's the dwellers how many seconds
It's dwelling on those frequencies
So um you can't their feedback treatment cannot match these frequencies any so
You can't can't do their feedback on the same frequencies
That you're running with the right there are feedback frequencies are tied to brain frequencies
Which are limited to from like two hertz to maybe 60 hertz if you want to
stimulate the hyperbeta range so your beta frequencies are your high
awake alert frequencies that are in
You know typically
24 to 30 range but can be you know
That's the bad thing about looking at screens all day screens like your computer screen or your TV screen
Is running at 60 hertz and 60 hertz is firing a super super high beta wave
That's why people can't get to sleep because you get to get down to a theta wave
4 to 7 to be able to get to sleep a day. That's one of the reasons why you get to sleep is because your brain is still like firing at 60 hertz
Maybe it's down to 50. I like to trade off the TV and it takes a balance where to get down to 20
How in the world are you going to fall asleep in a theta wave?
So
Your feedback treatment is stimulating the grade at different frequencies
Your alpha beta beta
Gamma wave frequencies
In a certain area of the brain to be able to stimulate it or call that or whatever you're trying to do based upon your
grade or your feedback scan that showed higher low and certain area to try to balance that out
Next question. I wonder if I if you can make those programs read only
So they're not modifying
No, you have to hit save in order to change it and if you know, I mean, it's meant to be able to modify
But
You can't make them read only if you
You could go in there and erase it all if you don't hit save it
It doesn't save it and if you close on to that program and you go to the other day program to go back to it
You'll see it again. It's only it's a rare that a person's this is up there program and it's almost always just a
Mistake a weird mistake. So
Can neuro therapy like neural feedback used in conjunction? That's right. Absolutely. It's just completely different
So you can do neurofeedback. That's right. neurofeedback is a completely different purpose
So neurofeedback is meant to change your brain waves to
To balance your your brain and it can't have an effect on
Your audit of experience is simply can't have benefits. So yes
I have it off chemo for three months most recent CT scan shows the tumor has grown slightly in all one centimeter
And colleges wants me to start chemo infusions in a few weeks
Is that considered a significant growth feeding chemo right away?
My number looks good and no mention of the testicists like the four. I use the right every day
Well, the other sense of that is really it depends
So if it was a quarter centimeter big before and now it's a one centimeter growth. So now it's a lot of the quarter
Yeah, that that's a big growth
If it was four centimeters and now it's showing five centimeters, you know, still there's some growth there
You do have to consider
pseudo enlargement reading is it really growth or is it
Inclimation around the cancer because my immune system is effectively attacking it. So it is really not growth
Um, I've talked about that a lot as in false that you do have to you do have to weigh out
Uh, uh, any test that's from CT scan gold standard
Um with other things, you know, probably symptoms and they got worse um, you know
Way it out with other signs and symptoms other tests, you know, depending on what organ it is
Do it ultrasound is that changed a lot to you know, weigh it out with those things
If there was truly the testicists in the liver before and they didn't say anything about it now ask
Okay, is there any of the tests in the liver? Is that gone or maybe I want to keep going the way I'm going right now
Or maybe I would just want to put a hold for a period of time
I can't really tell you what to do when you should do keyboard art
But those are the questions that you want to start asking. Is it pseudo growth?
Um, doesn't correlate with any signs and symptoms doesn't correlate with any other tests I'm doing
Doesn't correlate with um with uh with the tuber
Um, other tuber markers so you could do a blood test to see if it correlates with anything else
Yeah, forgot to ask about the liver that you know, maybe just go back to the see ask for the report and see if the report even
If this sometimes they'll do a CT if this is a breast CT and in a breast CT
Chest CT, but they didn't vote as far as the liver. They did last time. They didn't even see the liver
But on the radiology report, it should list all the organs and what the the radiologist saw or didn't see
Um, it's it was clean and should say
The spleen was observed to be cleaned and you know, they're radiologists, terminology and there was no abnormality
CT abdomen pelvis for sure it should have shown the liver so go back and look at that report
Um, it should be very clear
Okay, I couldn't find a picture of that
In the screenshot
Right
Any other questions
Fox I'm skipping the right if I'm on vacation like a motorcycle trip
Yeah, I mean you got to sway that out if you're going to be gone for a couple days and it doesn't make sense to bring it with because you're going to be moving every night and
Certainly I have limited space if you're driving on your motorcycle, well, it's got to be
You know, I
I'd say
Leave it alone. Go enjoy yourself
Joyment that you're going to have on it on your vacation is going to exceed anything else you do. So good for you
Your body and your immune system
So go enjoy yourself great
Any precautions when taking antibiotics for oral bacteria
Um, well if you've been suing this you have uh, this is
The diagnosed with the bacterial infection in your mouth there they're recommended um
Antibiotics orally
Um, yeah, there's
precautions in the fact that you're taking antibiotics. You're going to affect the
is uh, um, you're going to
Most likely cause some level of dysbiosis in the gut
The rest of the body you just kind of be aware of that against using antibiotics of just against it
Many times they're very appropriate
So just make sure that you are supplementing with the probiotic
You know, away from the antibiotic or you'll just kill them
You don't want to take it
Um, so let's say you take that when you take you there about twice a day the body that you did
Take some probiotics, you know, mid later morty to the early afternoon
So that you're just tried to combat the lack of
Laura the destruction of Laura that got
I would suggest that we have a really we have a new product that we're carrying really excited on it
Especially for all our breast cancer and head and neck cancer patients. We don't have any in yet
But it's um, it's
Product by biosighted um for oral care
And I ordered six of them
But um
We're already spoken for so I ordered
Bunch more goodness. It's just I'm gonna do this my wife's like I'm doing this
It's dental side it's all of you know
Biosighted is but biosighted is a great product that really helps kill bacteria
It helps break down biofilms. So it's commonly used
for um
Lyme disease
commonly used for Lyme disease and
um
And
It's great to break down biofilms
so
It's so this is specifically for
The mouth it's um, it's supposed to be a two-month procedure
You use this toothpaste for two months and you do a swish rinse spit
Since instructions on the like the kid
For two months twice a day. So you're brushing with this twice a day. You're a spit rinse
With this twice a day and the studies that are coming back got a really good to kill
Um the bad bacteria you want the good Laura in your mouth too
So the nice thing about bioside music doesn't disturb your floor
Your good floor. So this is killing the bad floor
um
It's uh, that's an exciting product
You see that a lot
This is just like a two-month procedure. You don't have to do
Um, you're a whole white but then they want to do it maybe twice a year
Uh, moxicillin three times a day. Yeah, then you're really hitting it hard
Um, but it's
Probably a short-term usage still you could take some probiotics between it. You could actually do this with it too
Are you familiar with totally a tongue red?
Uh, the the clinic where I get my knees that had amazing results for people who do long distance foam
Coal sleep with a practitioner
But he uses a doll where he taps with a hammer to identify blockages
And it feels
Like a little bit like booty three. I do know that booty can't heal
But it is at a cost of doing darkness to heal instead of god. They want me to do it
Um
Yeah, personally, if I wouldn't do it. That's just my spiritual belief
Uh, if somebody are you and I do well and a very strong faith
Um, in the Lord and they were doing something that seemed a little weird. I would maybe
Question it, but I might still do it because I trust that person and that they're seeking answers for the Holy Spirit
But if that's not the case and they're not a professed Christian
My personal belief is I wouldn't go to I believe the acupuncture works that I don't think it has a spiritual connotation
But I wouldn't quote with acupuncturists that is
You know, uh, he was not a believer. That's just me. That's my choice. You can make whatever choices you want
But that's my choice um, but um
There's sometimes I won't do because I think you've been open to the door
Uh for you know satan in your life and his demons and they're looking for open doors and they just think you just have to be careful
Um, even if you're not dealing with the serious disease you just need to be prayed on when what you're supposed to be doing and
Pray for protection, but then also means you don't do stupid things like general buildings
So you think God's gonna protect you so you do have to use COVID sense in understating scripture
And scripture is very clear about state away from magic or
Um, things like that too. That's why
We are very careful if we do physiology or really more and more to start prayer in our clinic
and um
So that's that's very important. So
All right
So that's where it comes in, you know, and everybody has their belief on this, but you're asking me these questions
It comes into I think it's very important that you have a strong biblical foundation
So some people go, oh, how do I know what God is doing? How do I know what God is saying you if you don't know scripture
How in the world do you know anything what God is doing? They're saying
After no scripture and how God worked in the past
Um, he's the same. He's never changed and um, some people go I really believe that told me to do this and I can say
fatically
There's no way God told you to do that. Well, how can you say that because there's no way my God would tell
You to do something like that that is so against his character
When you use when you read scripture over and over again, you start to understand God's character
And you start to understand what things he would and would it do so you listen to Joel Osteen say that God wants to make your rich
You've read your Bible you understand that that's my from
The pit because that's not what God wants in your life is to make you rich
Um, and you understand quite easily that that's not God's character. So
You should be able to be mature now to understand
Um, some of the simple things some of the milk of the world
You don't have to know the meat of the word that takes time and it takes a lot of study to
Grow in your relationship with God that you could discern
Um, the deeper things of the word, but you can't ever observe and
And understand the deeper things in the word and tell you start drinking the milk of the word
Which is you've got to start reading the word
It
It baffles me that people will sit and read novels for
Days and listen and and binge watch stout and abbey but they won't read the Bible
And so there's multiple avenues. There's no excuse for us today if you're an auditory listener. You could
Listen to the Bible on audible or if you're
You could watch video with your visual learner
By the Bible and scripture and
There's a lot of great teachers out there to be listening to too. So
But you'll know if they're great teachers or not if you don't go the word and God's character so that you don't get
dragged down a road that is
Unbiblical and
Not godly and it's not good for us
Ultimately and all things bad wants to to teach us
Um
And shape us and mold us to be more like his son. That's why picked this first for today
Um Paul was saying for our light affliction, which is about for a moment and I understand this is Paul who shipwrecked three times
Be to almost near death multiple times
39 lashes multiple times was you know ultimately that his head chopped off
Is saying while he's sitting in a jail cell a Roman cell which people friends don't bring you food
You don't eat or the rats are chewing at your feet all night long says it's only for a moment which work us in us
Far more exceeding and internal weight of glory. So when you weigh out the glory of eternity
Compared to all our struggles for today. It is quite a weight
So I'll leave you with that. Don't let it imprained for you. It was a long zoom call today
Keep praying for us since the devil's constantly trying to attack us and we're constantly praying for you
All right. Love you all. We'll see you next week